please welcome very funny David bori
[Music]
I already blew it I don't understand
love I don't I don't understand love
I've been trying to figure it out those
so recently I talked to a friend of mine
who has been in love and she broke up
with her boyfriend and I was talking to
her cuz on have sex with her and she
said the craziest thing to me she said I
don't think I deserve love anymore and
that bums me out cuz I don't think love
is the thing that you deserve
necessarily right terrible people have
found love Adolf Hitler found love
Charles Manson found love guy fieri
found love there's nothing it's just a
thing that might happen if you stick
around long enough it's like getting an
extra Chicken McNugget at McDonald's or
HPV the odds are just super good I feel
like if life is an ice skating rink
falling in love is like seeing a fat kid
fall down it's great if it happens but
you could have a good time without it
I don't like telling that joke cuz I
feel like you're all thinking about me
falling down it makes me feel like a
sellout to my fellow curvy boys cuz I
write I am super fat I'm also super good
at it
and that's the weird thing to be in this
life it doesn't make a lot of sense
being good at being fat is like kissing
your sister and then finding out you
have incredible chemistry it's not where
you want to be in this life but everyone
deserves a skill set I recently saw what
I think was the truest form of love I've
ever seen I was on the bus cuz that's
where that happens and I looked outside
and I saw a couple and they were wearing
matching do-rags and they weren't doing
it on like some kind of ironic throwback
to the 90s kind of thing they were doing
an honor it's Tuesday and this is what
we wear to the grocery store type and I
appreciate it cuz that's what I think
real love is it's being out of style
together
there's then real love is I'm gonna
airbrush your t-shirt you're gonna
bedazzle my golf Visor and then we're
gonna lace up these sketches and hit
this cold world together
I like to drink alcohol it's the thing I
like to do I think you guys are sad too
I uh I like outlaw I think in America we
do alcohol wrong though in America you
have to be 21 years old to start
drinking alcohol and I think that's not
correct I don't think that's how we
should do it in my opinion 21 should be
when you stop drinking because 15 15 to
21 were the greatest drunks in my entire
life
remember getting drunk at 16 you get
drunk you puke on the ground you touch a
buck it's all new you live it no 16 year
old ever got drunk and called his mom at
4 o'clock in the morning and asked where
his real dad is I'm trying to grow up
with the way I drink though so I
recently started drinking white wine Wow
white wine is so good it makes me wonder
what else white women have been hiding
from me this book makes me a better
person like I started drinking white
wine I was like David you know what
you're a white wine drinker now you
don't have to listen to rap music every
day you should slow it down so I started
listening to Sade and then I was like
you know what David you'll have to eat
that trash McDonald's food anymore
you're a white wine drinker so I started
cooking my own meals at home and then I
was like David you deserve the finer
things in life maybe just wear silk
scarfs at home just to see how it feels
just cuz you deserve it and the other
day I was doing all those things at the
same time I was cooking food I was
drinking white wine I was listening to
Shaw day and I had my head wrapped in a
scarf and I realized whoa wine turned me
into my mother
this is cool this is my first time I'm
late night I'm gonna get out of here I
just want you guys to know that I'm not
only a comedian I'm also an actor so I
have prepared a character to do for you
guys today this character is a Southern
gentleman I imagine him to look a lot
like Colonel Sanders and this gentleman
does not know that the word gay is not
short for alligator you're gonna get it
I don't know why they won't allow
alligators in the military they are
frightening same guy I heard in San
Francisco they have an alligator Pride
Parade sounds dangerous
and the third one which is by far my
favorite is I heard that letting
alligators adopt Chinese babies
responsible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you